vimos en la lección anterior que para
escribir un rate tracer se necesita una
forma matemática para contestar una
serie de preguntas donde se intersecta
un rayo con un objeto de la escena
el rayo de sombra alcanza la fuente de
luz antes de inter secarse con otro
objeto como se refleja la luz en la
superficie qué tan lejos está la fuente
de luz y por último dónde está la cámara
en lo que resta de esta lección nos
centraremos en el primer sub problema el
de la intersección del rayo con el
objeto
empezaremos nuestro estudio abordando
primero el problema más sencillo de cómo
realizar en dos dimensiones la
intersección de rayos con objetos ahora
bien como se ve el racing en dos
dimensiones comencemos con nuestra
situación tridimensional y tomemos una
sección transversal a través de este
plano blanco' que contiene la cámara y
la dirección de visualización
observa también que el plano blanco se
intersecta con la pantalla en la línea
misma que llamaremos línea de imagen
esto significa que si dibujamos solo lo
que está en el plano blanco obtendremos
una imagen como ésta y para facilitar
aún más el problema intentaremos primero
realizar la intersección con el objeto
más sencillo posible un segmento lineal
entonces aquí está nuestra escena es
simplemente un segmento lineal que
conecta dos puntos a ive para renderizar
la escena al igual que en tres
dimensiones
necesitamos seleccionar una ubicación
para nuestra cámara llamemos a la cámara
punto ce luego seleccionamos una
dirección de visualización como la que
se muestra aquí en rojo en tres
dimensiones la ubicación de la cámara y
la dirección de visualización definen
una pantalla pero en dos dimensiones nos
da una línea de imagen esa es la línea
sobre la que se formará nuestra imagen
ahora seleccionemos un punto p en la
línea de imagen para denotar el píxel
cuyo color queremos determinar
recordemos que el rey tracer construye
un rayo que va desde se atraviesa a peu
y luego se dirige hacia la escena
necesitamos una forma matemática para
calcular los puntos de intersección como
esta llamada i
para desarrollar las fórmulas
matemáticas introduciremos primero un
sistema de coordenadas la matemática que
necesitamos viene del álgebra de inter
secar un rayo con un segmento de línea
hemos presentado un buen número de ideas
en este vídeo así que usa el siguiente
ejercicio para asegurarte de estar
familiarizado con el racing en dos
dimensiones